Let me go next to our color
from the 201 area code, who's calling today
from 2001.
Hey David, this is Micky from your...
Hey Mickey what's up?
So an first of all, I just wanted to say that
someone who in 2016 voted for burning and
has actually
been following his career for many way before
even became popular, caused to be probably
further
to the lesson than you, honestly, at one point,
I've noticed as I've gotten all this and this
is a pretty
classic with many people who get older, we
become a little bit more conservative.
And I started to
really re­considered, on my ideas and at
the same time in 2016 I have noticed that
the progressive
left is just she liked us becoming me.
Like Franklin Israeli­American, is also a
sign.
I said, "tatio
many comes.
It's almost like, you tell people that you're
Israeli, and they just assume the worst in
you.
Now I see,
I just saw the video.
Some mom, 'cause...
And he literally just that...
Oh, I'm on for very...
Even though he's a Jew.
And that's confine today.
I don't think that would ever
been acceptable four years ago.
So I guess my point is, do you think that
the problem is in...
That's
probably not true, but do you think that any
of this, just extreme hyper­purity is warlike?
Oh, we're
better than you.
We know what's good and what's bad and if
you're bad, we don't even wanna talk to
you because there's no point of engaging with
Nazis, whatever they think, if you think any
of that
has to do with the failures of the Bernie
Sanders movement or is that just like has
nothing to do with
a...
Yeah, let's...
At earlier this earlier this week, I outlined
this there were three main problems with
Bernie's campaign and all three I've been
talking about for years.
A problem.
Number one is that a
lot of the policies that people like who are
in Berne circle are far less popular among
all Democrats,
so even Medicare for All is less popular among
all Democrats and so a lot of Democrats who
got in
the primary just didn't wanna vote.
For Bernie Sanders, that's one thing.
And that was under estimated number two, the
democratic socialist revolution stuff did
not help
Bernie Sanders.
Again, it's really great for rallies but as
we know, rallies don't win new elections.
It's really great for Twitter and read it.
But once again, I've been saying...
For, at this point, it's five
years.
I don't think there was any benefit for Bernie
calling himself a democratic socialist and
talking
about revolution.
And the number three is your pointing out.
Bernie has a lot of toxic people around
him including that Imam from Sunday night
in Dearborn, which we talked about, and other
people.
So if I had to say what are the real failings,
there?
It's not necessarily the issues, although
some of
the issues are actually less popular than
maybe we think when we look at Twitter and
read it I think
it's all three of those things put together.
So then the question is really, Why is he
embracing what benefit does Burnie at Le see
someone
who I think historically used to be much more
reasonable someone who, before he became super
famous, you see that you'd always...
Us in Congress, you as talking to people at
a teenage...
So
03/13/20 Page 11 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
there, I disagree with you, I, I don't think
Bernie's gotten any more radical.
I don't even describe him
as radical.
If you look at his policies, I think there's
just nothing to gain from using the language
of...
I'm a democratic socialist than we need a
revolution.
I think that's a strategic mistake.
I don't
actually think Bernie's any more radical today
than he ever was.
So the what benefit if he get embracing, to
leave and Noah who are like lead now is worth
basically
put the entire past eradicated is, which is
the biggest fear of all Israelis that...
But how can we cared
of us?
And then she goes and I out then she was to
sit literally, all Paul simple or over the
shirt and
where the thumbs up, in the picture.
And it's us like, Well, is what we've been
telling you that they
wanna destroy our country.
So then we kind of maybe rationally responds
with the extreme
violence.
Okay, I understand.
And then they are...
Fears are justified that they listen to.
I don't know what I very little about recite
to leave, I don't know what Bernie's calculation
is for
having her around.
I can only go by what Bernie says on the issue
of the Israeli­Palestinian conflict,
which is Israel has both a right to exist
and to defend itself and we need to work on
improving the
situation, for Palestinians as well.
And I'm behind that position that to lead
stuff or whatever, else I
know less about but I think it's important
to make...
You're kind of mixing a lot of different things
together.
It's important to look at each of these things
one by one.
Alright, interesting, okay, so you don't think
is really a connection there, alright, it's
not that these
things aren't connected.
Is that in the way that you're asking me?
I'm not sure I have any other
answer than to what Bernie is saying if that
makes sense.
Okay, interesting, okay, well, thanks David
type.
Alright, Mike, thank you for the call very
much
appreciate hearing from you that is going
to do it for calls today.
Sorry, I wasn't able to pick up on
everybody.
We will take call again, and I will hear For
more focus next.